you guys weren't prompted I didn't say a
word we have a brown man who's lived
here for two years who came from
Venezuela and said hey I'm blessed to be
the best country in the world and every
single person in this room shout at him
with your applause we're blessed to have
you back all right
yeah oh really
[Applause]
through a page I'm joking okay what's
your question sir okay so first of all I
would like to thank you and like
everybody here present because before I
came to this country two years ago
everybody told me and it was like common
culture that white people was racist and
everybody wished with a gun was a crazy
person but I want to thank you all to
prove that all that is wrong and I'm
blessed to be in the best country in the
world
[Applause]
you just talked about two years that you
been in this country and when you first
came to this country you should have
thought that white people were racist
anyone had a gun was crazy yeah like it
was funny because I didn't know English
that well whenever I came
yeah but nobody ever even made fun of my
accent I just read it but it's okay I
was more so making fun of you laughing
at your starving mother but here's
something that's really interesting to
me right when they want to say when the
left tried to say that the conservative
consists of mainly all right people who
don't who don't have a problem with the
illegal immigration who just have a
problem with anyone who isn't white
coming to this country
you guys weren't prompted I didn't say a
word we have a brown man who's lived
here for two years who came from
Venezuela and said hey I'm blessed to be
the best country in the world and every
single person in this room shouted him
with your applause we're blessed to have
you right back
because let me tell you something man
let me tell you something every now and
then I'll get some trolls who blah but
well can you name any single country
that's been successful that's had
immigrants ever they're gonna they're
gonna destroy Western culture every now
and then you do see some people who are
extremists like a lot a second are there
any societies have been successful with
immigrants I don't know I'd point to the
United States now what does that mean
it's important it's important to
understand right we didn't lose our
culture in the United States first off
when we created the Constitution that
all people were created equal and of
course back then most of them are white
because slavery was bad and then we kind
of fixed it on us we screwed up but we
didn't lose our culture when we
rightfully frida slaves we didn't lose
our culture when the Italians came over
we didn't lose our culture when the
Irish came over we didn't lose our
culture when the Polish came over we
lose our culture when the Jews came over
the only problem that we've had with
immigration is a modern leftist
philosophy that flies in the face of a
melting pot where people like yourself
come in to be a part of the great
experiment that is the United States of
America that's a very new idea a new
idea that you can migrate to this
country whether legally or illegally and
not take part in the culture not learn a
language and not be an American first
and that's why I have a real problem I'm
not as concerned with Venezuelan
Americans coming here who are
anti-american I'm more concerned with
anti-american Americans who want to
bring people in here who don't like this
country
and that's why if you line them up and
you give me a choice between an angry
raspy feminist with blue hair and a
[ __ ] hat or or even Elizabeth Warren
and some Bangladesh some Bangladeshi
who's coming here who wants to open up a
business and fly the American flag and
be a part of this culture guess what I'm
picked at [ __ ] every single time
so thank you so much do you have a
question yeah okay
so that's like James Brown okay can I go
down well I don't have any cool people
put a blanket on me sorry go ahead
no you're good so actually are those
caskets cool I'm sorry so actually my
only question I have been like amazed by
everything in America everything but one
thing I'm amazing at the same time happy
verify no hope popular socialism has
being here in America especially because
I have seen like yeah what what can it
do to a wonderful country and I really
don't want that to happen to America but
my question is why do you think it
became so popular over here because I've
never lived it
that's it I know I said you know I just
kind of went off gave you soliloquy the
truth is was it relates to socialism no
one here has ever actually lived it I
mean I know Bernie Sanders honeymoon in
a tent in the USSR but outside of that
no one's ever looked like I was raised
in Quebec which isn't socialist like
Venezuela but we do have a socialized
health care system we do about 52
percent income tax and it's actually you
don't be making that much to be in that
highest income tax bracket I lived it
and as it relates to like socialized
health care that's a good example right
here's what often happens okay this is
why I think they haven't lived it but
they also get tricked by the same media
who wants to silence Generation Z by the
way here's what you often see like let's
take health care for an example by the
way house health care in Venezuela
compare the United States stuff via free
stuff it's good no I already told you my
mom was starving so what they do and you
see this a lot from the left and I hear
this in the debates and I'm amazed this
is one thing that hopefully you guys
understand and see this sort of bait and
switch that happens a lot to left what
they do is they say hey hey the United
States we spend too much on health care
understood we do have a system that's
broken it's not flawless they say every
single other industrialized country has
socialized health care okay they're not
necessarily all the same kind of system
but I do understand they have something
more similar to what you would see a
socialized health care compared to the
United States and then they say they
spend less and by the way they have
better health care by the way they rank
Venezuela above the United States this
comes from two studies okay this is
important to know what they do is they
talk about health care and they talk
about the problems that we have in the
United States objectively and we do have
problems and then what they say is these
health care systems in other countries
are better and all of a sudden they
start pushing subjective ratings comes
from two studies comes from one as the
world
I think World Health Organization they
do their global rankings okay has the
United States ranked right between if
I'm not mistaken Slovenia and Colombia
yeah good go in next time you need to
have a root canal Pablo Escobar shows up
I mean it is unde there zanuck there's
one other one the more recent one was um
the Commonwealth study this is the only
two studies that I know of and by the
way the Commonwealth studies
Commonwealth I believe that was the
organization we wrote about on the
website they listed eleven
different countries for health care and
they ranked them and they said okay
these are the best from best to worst
you know who is ranked 11th the United
States do you know who is ranked number
one the UK now here's the thing how did
they come up with those rankings
does anyone here even if you're a
liberal does anyone here believe in our
health care is not as good as Cuba or
Slovenia for God's sakes no of course
not
what they do is say we have problems and
then they say these people have better
health care why because they're happier
with their health care well that doesn't
matter if I do somebody a [ __ ] sandwich
and they're happy because it's free it
doesn't mean that it's better than me
having a meal of broccoli and chicken
breast and quinoa right you can say all
you want that my meal is more expensive
and the person who's starving was a crap
sandwich is happier with it that doesn't
mean that it's objectively better than
the United States I'm amazed that nobody
talks about this more conservatives get
sucked into it a lot and they say well
these countries are ranked higher than
the United States okay let's take the
one that's ranked number one in the most
recent study guess what they have their
guess one of the objective outcomes
mortality rate your likelihood of
suffering of dying from a serious
illness it's two to three to four times
higher than a UK I think we have the
numbers it was like 2.5 times more
likely to die from breast cancer from
prostate cancer the wait times are
exponentially higher than the United
States drug development doesn't come out
of these countries but guess what people
who don't have to pay even if they're in
countries where they're paying 60
percent income tax right and they can't
afford a car like in Denmark because the
tax is so overwhelming so they all Drive
old gay Passats they think that their
health care is better because they see
it as free don't be fooled by the
rankings that list our health care lower
than other countries because of
subjectivity and people saying that they
like their health care more and that
tricks a lot of young Americans to go on
socialism must be doing it right it's a
lie it's not true you don't have to buy
it cut that [ __ ] off at the pass thank
you very much for your fun hey there
YouTube viewer if you like this video
click one of these other videos playing
in a box subscribe hit the notification
bell you may be wondering why after this
outlandish video this is such a straight
end card that's because we've recently
learned that end cards actually
determine the YouTube algorithm as it
relates to controversy on a sliding
scale
so we have a yellow and it escalates all
the way to the word